hello guys now I know I just released a
video regarding of a Spider-Man and
Spider-Man no way home but since then
somewhere else has been revealed so
there's been a huge editor mistake so
the scene where MJ is seeing falling
from the scaffolding holding the rail in
on the left side of the screen next to
Ned we can see another Spider-Man
holding this railing now I think this is
no other than Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
just because there's been numerous set
leak photos seen of Andrew Garfield
holding this exact same railing now I
think what would be really cool if this
is a scene where Tom Holland Spider-Man
tries to save MJ but fails and then
Andrew Garfield's rips in and then saves
her now this would bring It full circle
as unfortunately Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man failed to protect Gwen Stacy
in the exact same circumstances anyway
what do you think of this Edward mistake
whose arm do you think this is is this
Toby Maguire Spider-Man is this Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man who do you think it
is also everyone watch another video and
editing the mistakes from the Spider-Man
no way home trailer please check out the
previous video that I made on this topic
without the way please like And
subscribe to show your support thanks
for watching